Psychologist happiness is a continuous
state not only of present even of
future. There happiness can be
categorized into three different
types. The first category is false
happiness.
This false happiness is very short-lived
and some people may consume
drugs, alcohol,
intoxicants which gives them a delusion
of
happiness. But this delusion of
happiness is short-lived. The moment the
intoxication veins, the effect of the d
drug waines, happiness also disappears.
And then there is misery.
Due to which the person has more drugs,
more
alcohol, he then becomes a drug
addict
and this happiness is false happiness.
The first category which is short-lived
and only a
delusion. The second category of
happiness is the temporary happiness
which is achieved after achieving a
goal. You may want to come first in the
classroom. You may want to come first in
a race or want to win a boxing match or
you want to be a very rich man or you
want to become a doctor. You have a
goal. When you achieve the goal, you
feel happy. But this happiness is also
short-lived. But it is not as damaging
as the first category. Once you achieve
the goal, then again your state of
happiness disappears. So the second
category which is called as temporary
happiness is only short-lived when you
achieve a particular target. You have a
particular goal you have whether you
want to be a rich man or you want to
become a minister whatever goal you have
once you achieve you get happiness for a
short time after that it vanishes. The
third category of happiness is the true
happiness. This happiness according to
psych according to
psychologist and according to scientists
they say this happiness is a continuous
happiness and a
feeling of
enjoyment,
delight and
generosity. It's a continuous feeling.
It's not temporary.
And this continuous feeling of happiness
is unlike the first two category. It can
only be achieved on a
belief. If you have faith and if you
analyze the various types of belief that
you have in today's world, the only
ultimate to happiness can be achieved by
following
Islam. The religion of peace, the
religion of submitting your will to your
Allah subhanaa tala.
Many
people think how can they achieve
happiness and the most common that men
think is if you're rich you'll get
happiness. So something wealth will
bring you
happiness. Something power will bring
you happiness. Something that
fame and popularity will bring you
happiness. Something the more number of
friends will get you happiness.
Different people have
different standard of achieving
happiness. But let me tell
you all these
happiness few may fall in category one.
The remaining fall in category
two. You may think becoming a rich man
by becoming a millionaire or a
billionaire you'll be happy. If you see
the statistics of today's most richest
men, Elon
Musk, Jeff Bos, Bill Gates, all of them
divorced. Some of the children they
filed a suit against their father in the
court. Is this
happiness? The husband and wife
fighting. Imagine richest man.
All have been all of them have been
richest at least
once. So this is a false perception.